merci de nous retrouver en direct sur
Figaro live pour les vivre ensemble
l'hommage national rendu aux Invalides à
Jean-Paul Belmondo un hommage annoncé
dès le lendemain de la mort de l'acteur
lundi dernier à l'âge de 88 ans par la
président de la République une cérémonie
organisée par l'Elysée en concertation
avec la famille de Jean-Paul Belmondo la
cérémonie devrait débuter dans quelques
minutes vers 16h30 dans la cour
d'honneur de l'Hôtel des Invalides dont
on pourrait voir quelques images
maintenant 700 invités sont attendus la
famille les proches des représentants du
monde de la culture du sport et des
membres du gouvernement on a pu voir il
y a quelques minutes l'arrivée de Jean
Dujardin
Lelouch Samy Naceri Raffarin Jérôme
Commandeur Christophe Dechavanne les
copains de la banque du Conservatoire
sont représentés également par Pierre
Vernier dont on a vu la présence au sein
des personnes côté Richard Anconina est
également présent Michel Drucker
Nathalie Baye beaucoup de personnalités
donc vont assister à cette cérémonie
qu'on va commenter et vivre ensemble le
cercueil de l'acteur recouvert d'un
drapeau tricolore sera déposé au centre
de la cour des Invalides après avoir
passé les troupes en revue le président
de la République Emmanuel Macron devrait
prononcer l'éloge funèbre de celui qu'il
a présenté lundi comme un trésor
national qui parmi nos grands acteurs
était celui qui remportait haut la main
la palme du public les obsèques de
l'acteur se dérouleront quant à elle
demain matin en l'église
Saint-Germain-des-Prés à Paris à 11h
demain matin on y reviendra alors pour
cette cérémonie dont vous voyez en ce
moment les images en direct la cérémonie
n'a pas encore débuté on voit les
invités se présenter dans cette cour
d'honneur des Invalides c'est une
cérémonie qui se veut populaire à
l'image de l'acteur un millier de place
ont été découverte au public sans
inscription mais avec la présentation
d'un Pass sanitaire un public qui va
donc pouvoir assister exceptionnellement
à l'événement depuis la cour d'honneur
des Invalides mais pour tous ceux qui ne
pourront entrer deux écrans géants ont
été installés sur cette esplanade donc
vous voyez les images esplanade des
Invalides pour retransmettre la
cérémonie en direct pour ce public que
l'on voit en ce moment sur les pelouses
de cet esplanade des Invalides et
justement depuis cet esplanade des
Invalides on a Thibaut Isore qui est
notre envoyé spécial et qui se trouve
sur place devant cet hôtel des Invalides
Thibault ils auraient vous avez
peut-être pu échanger avec ces hommes et
ces femmes qui se sont rassemblés à
l'aube ce matin déjà pour être parmi les
1000 privilégiés qui ont pu entrer dans
cette cour d'honneur des Invalides alors
racontez-nous un peu ce qui se passe sur
place quels sont ces personnes qui se
sont déplacées c'est français qui sont
déplacés en nombre et quand ils
pensaient que de penser déjà de cet
événement
tu dis n'importe quoi
bonjour Charlotte bonjour à tous merci
de nous rejoindre pour une journée
historique pour la culture française et
la culture du cinéma mondial en tout cas
c'est bel et bien ce que ressentent ici
les gens qui sont rassemblés des
personnes qui étaient présentes à partir
de 7 heures du matin pour accéder aux
invalides ou pouvaient accéder et bien
près de 1000 personnes en tout cas au
niveau de la cour de l'autre côté des
Invalides alors à plusieurs dizaines de
mètres et bien se trouve ici l'esplanade
avec les pelouses sur laquelle et bien
ce sont rassemblés vous le voyez autour
de moi des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes avec également une grande
présence de médias internationaux j'ai
pu il y a la place observer la rail du
côté italien la CNN du côté américain
également la RTBF du côté de nos amis
belges donc vous voyez que de nombreux
yeux à l'international sont braqués sur
ces pelouses aujourd'hui ou bien autour
de moi se rassemblent encore un petit
peu des personnes devant bien la
projection que vous pouvez observer
derrière moi d'un court métrage de
pompiland des grands extraits de grands
films de Belmondo ça ça un métrage qui a
été monté par Thierry Ardisson et qui a
été validé par la famille même de
Jean-Paul Belmondo et du côté des
personnes rassemblées ici autour de moi
et bien beaucoup d'émotions j'ai
l'imaginais mais en tout cas pas de
morosité beaucoup bien de petits traits
d'humour j'ai plus notamment observer un
homme accéder aux Invalides de l'autre
côté faisant tomber au sol un nez de
clown qu'il avait amené en hommage au
film hold-up un autre homme lui alors on
essaiera d'aller le voir en fin de de
Slive c'est bien c'est amené ici en
caleçon à cœur avec un chapeau
haut-de-forme et des chaussures de
smoking ça c'est plutôt en hommage au
film Le guignolo donc vous voyez
beaucoup d'émotions une journée
historique mais en tout cas pas de
morosité pour respecter on imagine les
derniers mots de Jean-Paul Belmondo ne
pleurez pas
merci Thibault isaurait on vous retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour entendre
peut-être quelques témoignages de
français rassemblés sur cette pelouse
des Invalides pour assister à cet
hommage national à Jean-Paul Belmondo
Bertrand Guyard je me tourne vers vous
maintenant merci d'être en direct avec
nous pour commenter cette cérémonie
exceptionnelle et répondre aux
internautes du Figaro qui nous regardent
en ce moment vous êtes journaliste au
service culture du Figaro les Invalides
édifices du 17e siècle voulu par Louis
XIV sont un lieu évidemment chargé
d'histoire l'hommage national aux
Invalides il faut le rappeler est un
honneur qui est généralement et
habituellement réservé aux militaires
c'est une célébration rare pour les
géants de la culture pourquoi le choix
de ce site militaire aujourd'hui pour
rendre hommage à Jean-Paul Belmondo
c'est un lieu c'est un lieu solennel
alors c'est vrai que il est né en 33
Belmondo donc il a pas fait la Seconde
Guerre mondiale qui était trop jeune il
a fait je crois son service militaire
quelques en Algérie
mais il est grand officier de la Légion
d'honneur il est il est commandé des
Arts et Lettres donc s'il a reçu c'est
décoration
c'est parce que il s'est distingué pour
la France si c'est enfin je pense qu'il
a véhiculé
la grandeur ou le l'esprit français un
peu par en France en tout cas en Europe
et puis partout dans le monde donc via
il y a des gens qui sont qui ont été un
peu choqués par ça mais je pense qu'il y
avait des raisons il y avait des raisons
de lui rendre hommage ici
le choix de ce site militaire c'est le
président de la République je pense je
pense que ça c'est un accord avec la
famille c'est évident mais il y a que
lui qui puisse décider ça je crois
on se souvient évidemment des obsèques
en tout cas de l'hommage que populaire
et nationale qui avait été rendu à
Johnny Hallyday je crois que la famille
avait refusé les les Invalides justement
parce que en estimant que ça ne
correspondait pas aux personnages il
était belge Johnny déjà donc on pouvait
pas lui faire les choses
mais au fond
encore une fois c'est de toute façon des
gens qui ont fait vraiment la guerre si
maintenant il y a les militaires de
on va le préciser Bertrand guillière
depuis quelques années des personnels
des personnalités civiles sont mises à
l'honneur aux Invalides on se souvient
par exemple de l'hommage qui avait été
rendu à Charles Aznavour le 5 novembre
2018 les victimes des attentats du 13
novembre également avaient été mis à
l'honneur aux Invalides et puis on
citera par ailleurs Simone Veil et Jean
d'Ormesson également distinguer en ces
lieux on imagine Bertrand qu'il faut
avoir une aura ou un destin exceptionnel
pour être honoré de cette manière pour
les jeunes générations qui nous
regardent qui connaissent mal ou pas du
tout Jean-Paul Belmondo de quelle façon
a-t-il marqué les Français pourquoi sa
mort aujourd'hui en deuil tout un pays
je crois qu'il était sympathique
c'était un grand acteur on pourra en
discuter il a une filmographie avec des
grands réalisateurs mais c'était un
homme qui toute sa vie publiquement à
souris il a souri dans ses films il a
souri quand il était jeune et qui
passait dans les médias et il a continué
à sourire à ne pas montrer sa peine
lorsqu'il a été malade puisque on
rappelle quand même qu'il a eu un AVC il
avait il avait même pas 70 ans donc il a
passé les 20 dernières années de sa vie
quand même légèrement handicapé même
bien handicapé et il a continué à
montrer
le visage d'un homme souriant donc je
pense que c'était c'est son sourire et
puis alors d'autres choses c'est ce
qu'il était lui-même alors après on peut
revenir sur ce que sur on a beaucoup
écrit là-dessus mais c'est vrai que il
n'est le héros le héros Belmondo n'est
en 60 avec la nouvelle vague avec à bout
de souffle avec finalement lui-même en
rivet une gueule cassée une sale gueule
c'est ce qu'il avait dit au César un
homme qui a perdu son professeur au
Conservatoire avait dit mais avec vous
pouvez pas réussir avec une gueule comme
ça il a montré il a rajeuni l'image du
jeune premier en tout cas il a rajeuni
il a changé et donc c'est ça alors après
peut-être qu'effectivement les plus
jeunes parce que
Belmondo fait plus de fait plus à
l'affiche en haut de l'affiche depuis
malheureusement 25 ans mais d'abord on
voit les films et on l'a vu là pendant
le les heures passées qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont repassé à la télé naturellement ils
ont passé les films de deux Funès et de
Belmondo moi j'ai vu avec l'un de mes
petits fils on a vu l'âge des As il
était sidéré mais non mais c'est ça et
donc il a effectivement il a vu il a vu
il a vu un super Man et un clown en même
temps absolument
sur fig
Aro si de nous suivre et de vivre avec
nous cet hommage national rendu
aujourd'hui dans la cour d'honneur des
Invalides pour le comédien Jean-Paul
Belmondo l'acteur
l'aventurier du cinéma français et qui
bénéficient ou qui a les honneurs
aujourd'hui d'un hommage national voulu
par le chef d'État Emmanuel Macron et la
famille de Jean-Paul Belmondo vous le
voyez sur ces images la cérémonie se
prépare on attend les musiques d'un
orchestre symphonique on a pu voir
arriver des personnalités déjà on
s'était Jean-Pierre Raffarin parmi les
politiques il y avait également parmi
les personnalités du monde du cinéma
Jean Dujardin Claude Lelouch Samy Naceri
Christophe dechavan Jérôme Commandeur
Pierre Vernier dont on rappelle qu'il
est un des copains de la bande du
conservatoire de Jean-Paul Belmondo
Richard Anconina on se souvient
évidemment de son rôle dans l'itinéraire
d'un enfant gâté Michel Drucker Nathalie
Baye Bob Sinclar le DJ qui a pris ce
pseudo effectivement en clin d'oeil au
personnage de Belmondo dans le film Le
Magnifique Daniel Thompson est également
là la fille de Gérard
Oury avec lequel Belmondo a beaucoup
tourné on rappelle que le cercueil de
Jean-Paul Belmondo sera placé au milieu
de cette cour d'honneur avec un drapeau
français et qu'on me dit que le cercueil
devrait sortir sur la musique du
professionnel et il sera donc à la fin
de cette cérémonie de nouveau replacer
au centre de la cour des la cour de
l'Hôtel des Invalides qui sera ouvert
après la cérémonie à partir de 19h30 à
toutes les personnes qui souhaiteront
saluer l'acteur le public pourra se
recueillir à 19h30 devant le cercueil de
Jean-Paul Belmondo dans la cour des
Invalides à l'issue de cet hommage
national qui se tiendra je vous le
rappelle dans quelques minutes dans un
quart d'heure maintenant à 16h30 alors
c'est vrai qu'habituellement la cour des
Invalides pas ouverte au public à
l'issue des hommages nationaux mais on
se rappelle qu'elle l'avait été
exceptionnellement après le décès de
l'ancien président de la République
Jacques Chirac qui était mort le 26
septembre 2019 à 86 ans et des milliers
de personnes on s'en souvient c'était
recueilli sur son cercueil
Bertrand Guillard cette cet endroit ce
lieu très sauna très solennel et
protocolaire qui contrastent avec
l'image on va dire virevoltante de
Belmondo elle peut paraître un peu en
décalage on pouvait entendre ce matin
sur Radio Classique l'écrivain et
philosophe Gaspard Koni qui affirmé je
cite que l'État lui réserve un
enterrement de première classe cela ne
ressemble pas et puis dans un autre
registre Michel Drucker qui affirmait ce
matin chez nos confrères de France Info
que cet hommage officiel aurait fait
rire Belmondo parce que Jean-Paul
s'était un rigolo alors c'est frais
c'est vrai que certains Français vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure n'apprécie
pas certainement cet hommage national
peut-être que certains parmi vous qui
nous regardez y être même opposés vous
le trouvez que ça ne ressemble pas aux
comédiens et bien vous donner votre avis
sur le chat du Figaro et sur Youtube je
relierai vos commentaires en direct
Bertrand est-ce que on peut imaginer ce
qu'on aurait pensé Jean-Paul Belmondo
d'un hommage national tel qu'il va le
lui être rendu tout à l'heure je crois
que quelques jours avant sa mort c'est
un de ces amis Jeff de menech qui a
raconté que en riant certainement
on imagine j'ai pas il s'est amusait
peut-être de sa fin prochaine il disait
que voilà il se voyait bien
jeté d'un hélicoptère que son cercueil
soit acheté d'un hélicoptère bon c'est
pas parce que il était drôle pendant
qu'il a souvent joué les rôles comiques
il s'amusait qu'il avait du recul sur
les choses que au fond
il aurait je pense que ça aurait été
ridicule c'est plutôt le
faut raisonner par l'absurde si on
n'avait rien fait
au moment de la mort de la disparition
d'un grand acteur qui quand même qui a
fait plus de 130 millions d'entrées donc
qui était terriblement populaire je
pense que ça aurait été scandaleux aussi
donc alors choisir les Invalides bon
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure Charlotte
on l'a fait pour Aznavour on l'a fait
pour moi on voit Jack Lang arriver
ancien ministre de la Culture arriver
sur ces images
François Hollande Julie Gayet François
Hollande
prédécesseur d'Emmanuel Macron qui qui
arrivent également on avait prévu sa
venue beaucoup de personnalités donc du
monde de la culture des personnalités du
monde du sport également sont attendus
des personnalités politiques on le voit
avec l'arrivée François Hollande sur ces
images
les proches évidemment de Jean-Paul
Belmondo seront présents sa famille
Emmanuel Macron Brigitte Macron Emmanuel
Macron qui devrait
prononcer un éloge funèbre
beaucoup d'émotions parmi les
commentaires des internautes les
internautes qui nous suivent je les en
remercie beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup
soulignent
qu'ils sont tristes aujourd'hui et
triste depuis l'annonce du décès de
Jean-Paul Belmondo vous êtes nombreux à
nous faire part justement de votre
émotion sur Youtube en particulier
Sandrine Garcia à Dieu Monsieur Belmondo
vous avez été quelqu'un de très gentil
je vous ai vu il y a près de 25 ans
adieu Bebel grand acteur dit Anita
tatato également
toute ma jeunesse écrit Eric rommer
repose en paix Belmondo
d'inourdine Daoui
Christine Parmentier se souvient d'un
d'une phrase qui aurait dû Jean-Paul
Belmondo il me restera une très belle
parole de lui il n'existe pas d'homme
sans intérêt je pourrais lire comme ça
il y a peut-être une centaine de
témoignages parmi ce que vous écrivez
sur le chat de Figaro live sur Youtube
je les découvre en même temps que je
vous les donne Christophe Ragot salut
Bebel tu as bercé mon enfance merci à
toi tu resteras toujours vivant dans nos
cœurs vous le voyez sur ces images la
cour d'honneur des Invalides qui
s'apprête à
accueillir le chef de l'État qui devrait
prononcer un éloge funèbre pour
Jean-Paul Belmondo dont le cercueil sera
placé au centre de cette cour d'honneur
des Invalides 700 invités sont attendus
sont en train de s'installer on en a vu
certains arriver vous voyez sur les
pelouses extérieures de l'Esplanade des
Invalides le public n'a pas été oublié
1000 privilégiés sans inscription puis
entrer dans la cour d'honneur pour
assister à cette cérémonie et tous ceux
qui n'ont pas pu y entrer vous le voyez
sur ces images et bien peuvent se
rassembler librement sur les pelouses de
l'Esplanade des Invalides et peuvent
assister à la cérémonie grâce à
l'installation de deux écrans géants
justement sur cette planète des
Invalides on a le temps de retrouver
notre envoyé spécial Thibault isoret et
qui est en direct avec nous et qui
peut-être a pu recueillir le témoignage
de Français venus spécialement se
recueillir et assister à cet événement
exceptionnel
exactement Charlotte vous l'avez dit ils
sont nombreux à être venus ici observer
les images au plus près des Invalides et
de la cérémonie je vous propose de
partir à la rencontre de Pascal parce
qu'elle qui est venue avec ses français
aujourd'hui et bien vivre un moment
historique j'imagine Pascal pourquoi
est-ce que c'est important pour vous
d'être présent ici aujourd'hui un moment
historique est triste ouais pour moi
c'est c'est important là c'est vrai que
j'ai la chance d'être présent de que ma
venue parce que je suis pas parisien
mais coïncide avec ma venue pour avoir
professionnelle et j'ai tenu vraiment à
venir puisque BBL c'est toute ma
jeunesse pour moi c'est officiellement
la fin de ma jeunesse aujourd'hui
a le même âge qu'à mon père et
et je vais voir
[Musique]
et ouais je crois qu'on perd quelqu'un
de
compensé immortel peut-être et bon voilà
quoi
pas mal de jeux
moi le premier c'est justement depuis
quelques mois avec mon fils de 10 ans je
commence à lui faire aller faire
découvrir les belles et on se rend
compte que c'est intemporel il adore ses
films j'ai vu il y a combien il y a 15
jours on a vu avec lui il perd sur la
ville et ouais c'est c'est un personnage
qui est qui passe toutes les toutes les
générations en fait
ça va être dur mais un seul film
un seul c'est vraiment compliqué
je citerai quand même
je dirais peut-être faire sur la ville
pour moi c'était le film avec ces
cascades quand il était sur le métro là
qui m'avait fait rêver quoi ma
grand-mère c'est une bonne cérémonie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
il a exprimé toute son émotion et puis
avec des mots forts on l'entendait ce
monsieur qui nous racontait que c'était
la fin de de sa jeunesse c'est le décès
de Jean-Paul Belmondo retour sur la cour
d'honneur des Invalides il se passe en
début de cérémonie a priori puisqu'on
entend les trompettes de la garde
nationale si je ne m'abuse
on sait que le chef de l'État prononcera
dans quelques minutes l'éloge au funèbre
avant une minute de silence et la
cérémonie devrait être conclue par la
Marseillaise on laisse vivre ces images
je vous propose qu'on écoute et qu'on
regarde ce qui se passe tout de suite
[Musique]
alors qu'on vient d'entendre la
Marseillaise
et on le voit sur ces images une très
très belle photo grand format de
Jean-Paul Belmondo
dommage à Jean d'Ormesson Emmanuel
Macron avait déposé un crayon sur le
cercueil de Jean d'Ormesson est-ce que
là il va déposer un objet sur le
cercueil de Jean-Paul Belmondo il aimait
bien les voitures il aimait bien une
caméra
la salle le symbole d'une cascade c'est
difficile mais je sais pas ce qui peut
ce qui peut déposer pour un flingue
parce qu'il a joué souvent les voyous et
les flics non mais il peut pas pour pour
c'est un symbole c'est la plume pour
pour dormir son pour les photos seront à
mon avis ça m'étonnerait qu'il dépose un
objet
on verra dans quelques minutes alors que
la cérémonie s'apprête à débuter
[Musique]
on attend évidemment l'arrivée du
cercueil on le précisait tout à l'heure
un cercueil qui repartira en fin de
cérémonie sur la musique du
professionnel film de 1980 de Georges
Lochner dialogue d'audience de du
maestro Ennio Morricone un film avec
Robert Hossein évidemment qui
le fera rejouer au théâtre dans Kim
l'exercice d'Emmanuel Macron qui devrait
prononcer l'éloge funèbre sera
particulière pour le chef de l'État
puisqu'on imagine la teneur de son
discours ne devra pas avoir la raideur
un protocolaire des grandes cérémonies
militaires mais refléter évidemment
l'image populaire de Jean-Paul Belmondo
du grand avion Turier du cinéma français
j'adore Besson il jouait sa vie il
jouait son son rôle un acteur ça joue
plusieurs rôles alors c'est vrai que
pour Belmondo on se souvient de encore
une fois de de ces rôles de super-héros
d'agences secrets de flics de voyou mais
il a joué un prêtre il a joué un dans la
série Mississippi joue un homme
d'affaires qui est dominé par l'amour on
va pas faire tous ces rôles mais c'était
un c'était un artiste c'est quelqu'un
c'est un comédien c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui doit quand même malgré
tout soumettre
personnalité
au personnage qu'on lui con lui donne
donc je sais pas ce qui il est en
l'occurrence c'est vrai que pour
Belmondo la difficulté c'est que c'était
sa personnalité était tellement forte
comme pour les grands acteurs c'est pas
le premier c'est que parfois on a
l'impression que ils sont tellement
naturels qui sont eux-mêmes en donner
prêtre qui sont à un moment donné voyou
bon je ne sais pas ce qui va raconter
moi je pense qu'il va peut-être aussi
dire que au fond toutes ces tous ces
personnages de Belmondo c'était un peu
la France
il faut ils sombrera pas certainement
dans la dans la nostalgie mais on pourra
voir peut-être essayer d'en faire une
synthèse une fois qu'on leur a écouté
on le voit sur ces images de public
rassemblée sur l'esplanade des Invalides
un public qui n'a pu entrer dans la cour
d'honneur évidemment ou seul n'était
autorisé que
1000 particuliers on va dire or les
invités là ce sont des gens qui sont
rassemblés devant les écrans installés
sur l'esplanade des Invalides la
cérémonie va démarrer dans quelques
secondes maintenant
il y a beaucoup de jeunes dans le public
on le voit
en tout cas des des personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément connus Jean-Paul Belmondo
au moment où il était au sommet de sa
carrière et qui l'ont découvert un peu
plus tard vous êtes encore une fois très
nombreux à nous faire part de votre
émotion sur les réseaux sociaux du
Figaro je vais citer pillicailler bon
voyage monsieur Belmondo Jeff le franc
hâte Dieu Monsieur Belmondo il vous aura
juste manqué un peu de souffle pour nous
accompagner encore quelques mois voire
quelques années et nous aider à
traverser cette époque si peu souriante
Laura Didier nous dit mes sincères
condoléances à sa famille qui repose en
paix
condoléances évidemment pour beaucoup
d'entre vous à l'attention de la famille
de Jean-Paul Belmondo
voilà merci encore pour vos témoignages
et votre émotion sur sur les réseaux
sociaux du Figaro on va vous faire vivre
cette cérémonie en direct depuis la cour
d'honneur des Invalides une cérémonie
qui devrait débuter dans quelques
minutes à peine elle est attendue pour
débuter à 16h30 avec évidemment
l'arrivée du cercueil du comédien en
présence donc comme je vous le disais de
700 invités du monde du de la culture du
monde du sport et puis personnalité
politique et encore une fois puisque
Emmanuel Macron Brigitte Macron seront
évidemment là Emmanuel Macron devrait
prononcer l'éloge funèbres et puis on a
vu l'arrivée de Jack Lang Jean-Pierre
Raffarin est également là parmi les
personnalités du cinéma Arielle Dombasle
est arrivé il y a quelques minutes
Albert Dupontel mar du jardin sont là
évidemment
l'orangera et la Richard Anconina
Claude Lelouch Samy Naceri Pierre
Vernier dont je rappelle qu'il fait
partie des copains de la banque du
Conservatoire est-ce que Françoise
fabien est là alors je n'ai pas cette
info là pour l'instant c'est la dernière
c'est la société la fille et la dernière
vivante avec Pierre Vernier de la bande
de la bande du Conservatoire
je rappelle que
dans les mots ou quoi prononcé Emmanuel
Macron qui a écrit Emmanuel Macron à
l'annonce de la mort de Jean-Paul
belmonteau il a dit de Jean-Paul
Belmondo qu'il était celui qui
remportait haut la main la palme du
public Guillaume Canet est également sur
place il est question que Alain Delon
soit présent également on pourra en
reparler si on a le temps d'Alain Delon
évidemment de ce duo extraordinaire du
cinéma français Alain Delon dont on va
dire que c'était plutôt le taciturne
enfin c'est un Jean-Paul Belmondo qui
était
ultra solaire
c'était des amis
ils étaient rivaux ils étaient rivaux
ils étaient rivaux ils ont été je crois
amis sont connus très jeunes on sait
qu'ils ont un peu baguenaudé très jeune
à Saint-Germain ils ont deux ans
différents
et puis il y a une petite rivalité vraie
professionnelle autant de Borsalino
puisque on connaît l'histoire de l'ont
été producteurs
mais
de long à tous les les deux bons hommes
ont joué plus d'une fois ensemble ils
ont fait leur premier film ensemble ils
ont rejoué dans paris brûle-t-il qui
était inquiété quand même un film
historique ils ont joué dans borsalino
ils ont joué 20 ans après dans
vous interrompre Bertrand Guyard on voit
à l'image le premier ministre Jean
Castex à ses côtés Roselyne Bachelot
ministre de la Culture tout ça annonce
que le Président de la République
devrait arriver incessamment sous peu
président de la République qui devrait
prononcer l'éloge funèbres
je vais vous parler de la musique
d'Ennio Morricone qui sera joué par la
garde républicaine à l'arrivée ou au
départ du cercueil de Jean-Paul Belmondo
on a pu arriver au préalable un certain
nombre de personnalités qui se sont
installés parmi les invités
la
photo de Jean-Paul Belmondo magnifique
photo qui a été disposé dans cette cour
d'honneur des Invalides un très grand
format est à côté de l'orchestre de la
gare républicaine qui va qui va donc je
vous le disais je vous la musique Desnos
on attend on a entendu tout à l'heure
la Garde Républicaine jouait la
Marseillaise je parlais d'Emmanuel
Macron qui va délivrer les loges fines
mais il était lui-même sincèrement un
fan de Jean-Paul Belmondo je crois que
dans son panthéon cinématographique
figure un singe en hiver d'Henri
Verneuil dans lequel évidemment on se
souvient bébé était à doubé par Jean
Gabin autre monument du cinéma français
et vous qui nous regardez et qui est
mieux Jean-Paul Belmondo peut-être
avez-vous également un film qui vous a
beaucoup marqué de Jean-Paul Belmondo
que vous avez regardé de nombreuses fois
ou juste une seule fois mais qui reste
dans votre cœur et ben parler nous en
sur le chat du Figaro sur Youtube et sur
le Figaro.fr je relai vos témoignages et
vos commentaires en direct on attend le
début de cette cérémonie
vous avez un film préféré vous Bertrand
Guillard de Jean-Paul Belfort
moi je pense qu'il faut il y a plusieurs
Belmondo donc vous avez le Belmondo de
jeunesse avec la nouvelle vague je pense
à bout de souffle les Dédé des ferres
chauds de Melville le boulot donc ça ça
correspond Pierrot le fou quand même qui
était son défi
que j'aime beaucoup puis après vous avez
le Belmondo via Voltan et donc l'homme
de Rio c'est l'un des premiers films que
j'ai vu de dans ma vie quand même où il
a eu une sorte de tint franchir en os
quand même c'est quelque chose
d'étonnant qui qui inspiré Spielberg et
son Indiana Jones le magnifique
Steven Spielberg le réalisateur
américain a dit qu'il avait été inspiré
par Jean-Paul Belmondo
magnifique qui lui inspiré je dirais au
SSL les ESS 117 aujourd'hui c'est à dire
cette caricature de de James Bond sauf
que c'est là où le où vient un talent
fou c'est qu'il joue un double rôle
justement Bebel il joue le rôle de Bob
Sinclar et je joue le rôle de de Merlin
qui est un qui est un écrivain raté et
dans les deux rôles il est bon
et quand il joue
la caricature de l'agent secret mais il
est agent secret c'est une caricature
alors que lorsque Dujardin joue une
caricature de l'OSS 117 c'est une règle
c'est une réelle caricature et puis
après effectivement tout à l'heure vous
l'avez noté il est revenu au théâtre à
la fin de sa vie alors le théâtre c'est
pas capté ou c'est mal capté mais il
était Cyrano de Bergerac il était Kin
c'est Alexandre Dumas
d'Alexandre Dumas je vous vois en direct
on voit arriver le président de la
République avec à son bras Brigitte
Macron son épouse il a salué les
militaires à son arrivée
il arrive dans cette cour d'honneur des
Invalides le président de la République
d'où va se dérouler donc cet hommage
national à Jean-Paul Belmondo
si on peut monter un petit peu le retour
son
[Musique]
le président de la République s'annonce
seul au milieu de la cour d'honneur des
Invalides
[Musique]
alors que le chef de l'État Emmanuel
Macron vient de passer en revue les
troupes
il va peut-être aller saluer quelques
invités avant de se mettre à la place
qui lui est réservé on attend le cercle
qui devrait prendre place au milieu de
cette cour d'honneur des Invalides ou à
se dérouler donc cet hommage national à
Jean-Paul Belmondo
[Musique]
du drapeau tricolore
et il va être déposé au milieu de cette
couronne
[Musique]
alors je ne les ai pas vu je vous fais
confiance Bertrand Guillard ce sont les
décorations reçues par Jean-Paul
Belmondo
qui donc suivent
ce cercueil porté par la garde
républicaine
la Légion d'honneur le 8 novembre 2019
du Mérite
Jean-Paul Belmondo avait donc été décoré
en novembre 2019 par Emmanuel Macron en
présence
de son ami Robert Hossein
ce sont les petits enfants de Jean-Paul
Belmondo
très ému me dit-on je n'ai pas vu sur
ces images
qui se place
sa dernière fille à 18 ans
peut-être
parce que c'est son fils aîné
c'est Victor Belmondo le petit fils du
comédien qui devrait faire un discours
monter un peu le son en régie pour nous
en plateau merci
une qualité de son suffisante pour
l'instant pour entendre ce que dit
Victor Belmondo qui
délivre en ce moment un discours
le soleil ne s'éteint pas
il brille il a dit partout tout le temps
lorsqu'il se couche
quelque part il se réveille ailleurs
et notre grand-père nous ira dit et nous
ira dire à toujours de son sourire
sa bonté son extrême bienveillance
il est un soleil éternel
merci papi de nous avoir donné tant de
joie
merci d'avoir tant partagé ta positivité
tu nous laisses remplis de ce bonheur
immense
on pense à toi on t'aime
et amuse-toi bien avec tes copains qui
t'ont tant manqué
il y avait cette jeune fille aux cheveux
longs blonds qui est la fille dernière
fille de Jean-Paul Belmondo Stella
donc Alessandro Victor qui a fait le
discours c'était là et puis c'est neveu
certainement et il avait Alain Belmondo
avait des enfants
maintenant on est à la
donc la dernière fille de Jean-Paul
Belmondo qui a donc au bout de guerre 18
ans à peu près
son fils
Paul Belmondo doit avoir 56 ans 58 ans
56 ans peut-être 57 ans
alors qu'on voit le chef de l'État qui
se déplace qui se dirige vers
son pipi pour prononcer l'éloge funèbre
et on le voit ce magnifique portrait
de Jean-Paul Belmondo
qui trône donc au milieu de la cour
d'honneur des Invalides
parce que sur ce portrait là il y a pas
loin de 80 ans mais Google
extraordinaire
monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Président de l'Assemblée
nationale
monsieur le Président de la République
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Madame la Maire
de Paris
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
Mesdames et Messieurs les élus
chers famille Belmondo
mesdames et messieurs
Jean-Paul Belmondo était de la famille
frère cousin oncle
amis séducteur père hors norme héros aux
mille visages dont la carrière charit
mille vies dans lesquelles nous
retrouvons tous un peu des nôtres
et qui ont scandé si décennies de vie
française
mythologie d'une France heureuse
où la jeunesse prit tous les droits
détend insouciance puis des temps de
doute
si décennies de cavalcade à nos côtés
si décennies de théâtre et de cinéma
d'abord où il embrassa tous les gens
la gueule que l'on voulait voir dans les
salles obscures la gouaille qui
réchauffait les soirées télévisées des
Français
Belmondo
fut la figure qui transperce à l'estime
traversa les époques
cassa toutes les barrières
d'abord
icône de la nouvelle vague avec Jean-Luc
Godard puis François Truffaut star
inégalé du cinéma français et populaire
avec Henri Verneuil Girard Oury Philippe
de Broca Jean Becker Georges Lautner
Louis mal doré Philippe Labro Claude
Lelouch et tant d'autres
hommes de planche avec Robert Hossein et
Bernard Murat
présence inoubliable désinclassables
Jean-Pierre Melville Alain rainé Claude
sauter ou Claude Chabrol
il fut tour à tour génial improvisateur
et servant des dialogues sans égal
interprète orfèvre cascadeur hors pair
survolant Venise accrocher un trapèze
héliportée dans le guignolo dont le
temps un tigre sauvage dans l'animal
cheminement suspendu à un fil d'acier
entre deux immeubles dans un homme à Rio
mais là
toujours
les jeunes premiers des années 50
pouvaient laisser place au film est vrai
de la Nouvelle Vague
Belmondo était là
la couleur pouvait définitivement
supplanter le noir et blanc Belmondo
était là
Hollywood pouvait briller ses vedettes
conquérir l'Europe
Belmondo était là
avec sa bande du Conservatoire
Annie Girardot Michel Bonn Guy Bedos
Bruno Kremer Jean-Pierre Marielle
Jean-Pierre Mocky claudry Jean Rochefort
Philippe Noiret et bien sûr Françoise
Fabian et Pierre Vernier aujourd'hui à
nos côtés
il ne cessa de se renouveler se
réinventer et se faisant
de conquérir les générations successives
il est cette présence
avec laquelle on vieillissait de films
en film
de style en style
toujours le même
toujours changeant
Jean-Paul Belmondo a vécu à nos côtés
cette vie française
passeur entre Jean Gabin Pierre Brasseur
quelques autres et les nouvelles
générations
immortelle non seulement par ses films
mais parce qu'il enseigna son art de la
scène et du jeu à vous
Jean Dujardin
Antoine Duléry Richard Anconina Gilles
Lellouche qui était devenu sa nouvelle
bande et qui est là
en cet instant pour reprendre son
flambeau
durant ces décennies
Jean-Paul Belmondo embrassa pas
seulement les époques et les genres
il épousa la France
lui qui par tous ces rôles traversa à
grandes embardées l'histoire de notre
pays
le voici sous la régence mi soldat mi
bandit de grands chemins
puis remarquable mariés de l'un d'eux au
creux d'un arbre petit matin avec celle
dont il devait divorcer
pilote boxeur de la guerre d'eder dans
l'As des As sublime soldat désabusé du
week-end à zuydcote chauffeur
poids-lourds voyous sur les routes du
Sahel pour les cent mille dollars au
soleil inoubliable légionnaire des
morfalous
Belmondo
fut le visage de tous les
bouleversements de notre entre glorieuse
sans prétention
sans jamais chercher à porter une thèse
juste être là
un carnet
un jour prêtre assiégé par les
interrogations métaphysiques dans les
Morins un autre industriel et patron de
presse héritiers venus d'Amérique
critique assise de la société de
consommation dans le corps de mon ennemi
espion superbe en mission au Mexique
sous la légende bancale d'un écrivain
perdu flic voyou magnifique toujours
Jean-Paul Belmondo habitat la France
tous ces lieux que sa démarche chaloupée
sourire
lumineux
nos champs
sur lesquels fut abattu la tendre
crapule d'Abou de sous
ce château de Maintenon qui servit de
décor à la fin de parcours du
professionnel
cette Riviera azuréenne qui résonne
encore de l'élégance du mi-flic ni
voyons ces rues de Marseille qui ne sont
pas seulement celle de l'escoumoune mais
le théâtre dans lequel Londres de Bebel
restera à jamais mêlée à celle d'Alain
Delon seul complice à sa mesure
ce village de la Côte Fleurie
et tant d'autres et les trains qui
l'emprunta et l'égard qui l'arpenta
Nantes Besançon Lille les yeux
ces rues c'est place ces paysages de
France
nous aimons Jean-Paul Belmondo
parce qu'il me ressemblait
géant parmi les géants il était surtout
cet homme parmi les hommes que décrivit
son voisin d'enfance Jean-Paul Sartre
on l'admire
il nous fait rire
belle mondo c'est un peu nous en mieux
un jour de tournage Jean Gabin lui lança
impromptu
embrasse-moi un mec t'aimer 20 ans
oui
Jean-Paul Belmondo était nos 20 ans
ce jeune homme au nez cassé à qui l'on
prédisait un sombre à venir
professionnel et affectif et qui a force
de travail acharné depuis l'eau limitée
de charisme enveloppant finit par
conquérir la France et séduire les plus
belles femmes du monde
Jean-Paul Belmondo était notre entente
ce don Quichotte des temps modernes est
capable de repousser les limites de
l'ivresse en même temps que celle de la
tendresse tel un singe en hiver
Jean-Paul Belmondo était nos 40 ans ce
commissaire aussi athlétique qu'un
trépide que tous nous aurions rêvé
d'être pour nous battre contre la peur
sur la ville
Jean-Paul Belmondo était nos 50 ans
cette entrepreneur a succès qui soudain
choisi dernier étape de l'itinéraire
d'un enfant gâté de larguer les amarres
vers sa liberté et vers son destin
il fut l'ami que chacun aimerait avoir
lui qui jusqu'au bout convient son
acolyte de toujours
Charles Gérard Charlot pour refaire le
monde chaque midi comme chaque soir
il fut le fils que tous les parents
rêvent d'avoir
capables de refuser une statuette des
Césars parce qu'elle n'avait pas été
conçue par son père
et de passer des heures aux cheveux de
sa mère aveugle lisant des pages et des
pages de ces romans préférés
il fut le père exemplaire qui pourrait
lever ses enfants
n'hésitez pas à refuser tout tout
tournage en juillet comment nous
et le grand-père
que vous venez à l'instant avec émotion
de décrire
Belmondo
c'est la tendresse
parisien au sang italien amoureux de la
langue ancienne le temps que de l'argot
parisien tendre turbulent bourgeois
boxeur athlètent incroyable criblée de
fêlure Jean-Paul Belmondo raconte nos
contradictions nos failles
on aime sa solitude son goût du risque
l'élégance de sa joie
son style
à chaque fois
il fit la chronique de nos vies
d'un monde triste et tendre et cruel
réel et surréal terrifiante et marrant
nocturnes et diurne
solide et insolite beau comme tout
au fond
c'est peut-être Pierrot
qui dans sa douce folie maquillée de
bleu parler le mieux de Belmondo
cherche un sol
pour toutes ces raisons
vous perdre aujourd'hui pour tant de
Françaises et de français
c'est perdre un immense acteur
un long moment enchanté de cinéma
français
et une part de nos vies
et si malgré le chagrin
il nous faut sourire ce jour comme vous
n'avez jamais cessé de le faire
c'est parce que nous savons que vous
continuerez de nous accompagner
qu'il nous suffira pour retrouver votre
voix solaire de pousser la porte d'une
salle de cinéma
d'allumer une télévision un écran
alors à nouveau
la magie opéra
et depuis le siège passager d'une
voiture rose avec des étoiles vertes
nous pourrons crier que finalement nous
aimons la mer nous aimons la montagne et
nous aimons la ville rien à [ __ ]
sur la place du Trocadéro nous vous
suivrons dans une poursuite endiablée au
volant d'un cabriolet
et dans les rues plus vieux d'une
station balnéaire normande nous nous
livrerons aux joies d'une corrida
nocturne d'un feu d'artifice improvisé
et nous en donnerons quelque chose
arrosé d'un doute parfum de Yang
et au creux de notre oreille
on entendra peut-être murmurer ces vers
écrit par Cyrano que tant de fois vous
avez incarné et qui résonne si fort en
ce moment
et puis mourir n'est rien
c'est achevé de naître
alors j'en suis sûr
votre visage s'illuminera
de ce sourire inoubliable
sans amertume jamais
sans plainte
juste là
et comme un GLA
sonnera ce mot que tant de fois vous
prononciez
pour signifier tous les autres que vous
ne pouviez plus dire
voilà
vive la République vive la France
accepter par le chef de l'État Emmanuel
Macron qui a duré une dizaine de minutes
un quart d'heure si je ne me vingt
minutes près 20 minutes si je me trompe
pas
qu'on avait une pensée Bertrand Guillard
il y a des mots forts qui ont été
prononcés par par le chef de l'État j'ai
relevé mythologie d'une France heureuse
si décennie de cavalcade génial
improvisateur une gouaille solaire un
cascadeur hors pair et puis il a parlé
également de l'élégance de sa joie et
qu'il a traversé d'autres époques à
grande embardée ça reflétait bien le
personnage de Jean-Paul Belmondo ce
discours là
il a au fond assez ligament quand même
il est revenu sur toute sa carrière sur
toute cette sur tous les rôles il a
écrit une biographie belle qui
s'appelait millevil va mieux qu'une
parce qu'au fond ils condensait
condensait dans sa personnalité tous les
rôles qu'il avait joué il est revenu là
dessus et au fond en écoutant en
écoutant ce discours moi je connais tous
ces films donc je revoyais les scènes je
revoyais les scènes effectivement je
voyais passer c'était un discours plutôt
bien écrit il a été oui c'était nos
vingt ans c'était nos 30 ans de 40 ans
de 50 ans il a raconté tout ça il s'est
approprié ça il faut pas qu'on soit naïf
non plus mais il le fait plutôt bien
je sais pas qui lui a quelqu'un qui lui
a écrit certainement ses discours mais
en revanche il a fait une ce qu'on
appelle une belle nécrologie 12 minutes
de discours conclus par adieu Bebel le
président qui se recueille désormais
devant le cercueil de Jean-Paul Belmondo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et de nouveau les applaudissements après
cette marseillaise interprétée par le
coeur de l'armée
le chef de l'État recueilli devant le
cercueil recouvert d'un drapeau
tricolore
cercueil de Jean-Paul Belmondo
il y a quelques minutes le chef de
l'État prononcé un éloche funèbre d'une
dizaine de minutes 12 minutes pour être
précis dans lequel il a rappelé que
Jean-Paul Belmondo était de la famille
Hérault mille visage mythologies d'une
France heureuse il a travaillé traversé
toutes les époques il a cassa toutes les
barrières ne cessa de se renouveler de
ce réinventer
Jean-Paul Belmondo habitat à la France a
dit Emmanuel Macron Belmondo c'est la
tendresse a-t-il également dit il a
achevé son éloge funèbre par un adieu
Bebel suivi des applaudissements de la
foule présente dans cette cour d'honneur
des Invalides
républicain qui porte sur un coussin les
insignes
de grand officiers à les gens d'honneur
et grands officiers de l'ordre national
du Mérite qui avait reçu Jean-Paul
Belmondo
EUR des Invalides et a priori on devrait
entendre la musique du professionnel
c'est l'Orchestre de la Garde
républicaine qui devrait jouer cette
musique d'Ennio Morricone
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'émotion de Jean Dujardin
et des personnalités du monde du cinéma
qui l'entoure on a reconnu le comédien
Philippe Lellouche si je me trompe pas
également très ému
l'émotion et tout à fait palpable et
présente auprès des personnalités nous
sommes nous-mêmes émus je vous l'avoue
maître en Guillard et moi-même
cette musique est très
[Musique]
on le voit
dans le professionnel
[Musique]
vous voyez donc sur ces images je crois
que c'est Daniel Thompson non c'est pas
Daniel Thomson
[Musique]
clair un peu plus loin on a reconnu
plein de visages oui on peut pas tout
[Musique]
tous les cités ils sont professionnels
redémarre sur cette scène finale oui il
disparaît
je crois qu'on est en train perçu Paul
doux celui de derrière également le
l'écrivain qu'on a pas vu depuis fort
longtemps
[Musique]
chez Lelouch on sentait que c'était
terrible oui oui on voit pas le solaire
François Hollande l'ancien président de
la République Daniel Thompson également
donc Fernandez le joueur de foot
c'est difficile alors je les ai cité
tout à l'heure on les a vu arriver en
partie ils étaient très nombreux mais du
milieu du cinéma de la culture et de la
politique évidemment il doit y avoir des
boxeurs aussi certainement alors on en a
pas vu
mais
probablementozel qui était à lui un
boxeur professionnel qu'il a fait jouer
dans au moins une dizaine de ses films
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jouer le rôle de Charles Vanel c'était
40 ans après je crois non
avec une veste blanche qui a 90 ans
700 personnalités étaient invitées pour
assister à cet hommage national donc
que nous avons fait vivre en direct et
qui se déroulait
dans la cour d'honneur des Invalides
vous situiez Bertrand Guillard la
présence de boxeur évidemment Brahim
Asloum était là apparemment parmi les
invités
à la vie à club avec charger rare on
sait que il se débrouillait toujours
évidemment pour avoir des des combats de
boxe enfin des duels dans un sou dans
souvent dans ces films et que
et surtout il était très copain avec ce
Maurice aux ail qui avait été champion
de France dans sa catégorie et qui a
fait jouer au moins une dizaine de fois
dans dans ses films
Christophe Dechavanne Michel Drucker
une cérémonie particulièrement émouvante
en particulier lors du départ de
cercueil sur la musique du professionnel
qui bouleverse tout le monde on a vu le
public également qui a pu être présent
dans cette cour d'honneur et qu'on a vu
applaudi au départ
c'est c'est pas quelque chose de
déplacer
normalement on a ça peut se faire vous
êtes toujours aussi nombreux sur le chat
du Figaro en particulier sur YouTube à
nous exprimer votre émotion
Jean-Patrick bladey que je cite sur
Youtube super la musique du
professionnel et merci aux Figaro pour
cette belle retransmission merci à vous
de nous avoir fait confiance et de nous
avoir suivis en direct
super musique du professionnel que j'ai
adoré di Daniel Bresson
on a vu il y a quelques minutes de Bob
Sinclar un le DJ dont on disait qu'il
s'était largement inspiré
du personnage de Bébel pour trouver son
surnom de scène
peut-être on peut retrouver Thibaut
isorel autre envoyé spécial qui est
normalement en direct également mais
cette fois-ci du côté à l'extérieur des
Invalides sur l'esplanade des Invalides
où se trouve le public qui n'a pu entrer
dans la couronneur des Invalides et qui
et qui a pu assister en revanche en
direct à cette cérémonie grâce à deux
écrans géants installés sur place
effectivement pour un hommage comme
celui-ci on peut être surpris que les
gens applaudissent
le cercueil de l'acteur décédé
au fond encore une fois c'est je pense
que pour pour Belmondo c'est encore
moins déplacé parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui est toujours
travaillé pour le public encore une
parce qu'aujourd'hui on oublie beaucoup
qu'il a été décrié pendant un temps
quand il a fait surtout ce qu'on
appelait ces belles montrées il s'est
cascades ce ce cinéma très populaire
dans les années surtout 70-80
on disait qu'il avait oublié que
finalement il cédait à la facilité donc
maintenant on se rend compte que tout ça
fait partie d'une oeuvre
et que on peut faire des films quand on
a un grand acteur comme lui on peut
faire des films d'action et des films
des films intellectuels mais donc il
faut c'est au fond ces applaudissements
c'est l'applaudissement de toute sa pour
toute sa carrière et c'est
dont on annonçait la présence alors on
l'a pas vu je ne sais pas s'il était là
en définitive
il était très touché quand on l'a
entendu il a réussi
à chaque fois
il s'est rapproché il se sont rapprochés
l'un de l'autre ils ont fait une chance
pour deux il y a déjà une à 25 ans qui
était avec un critère clin d'œil alors
grandes années non ils étaient rivaux
mais je pense que les les deux hommes
s'admiraient évidemment s'admirait comme
de je sais pas il va y avoir ça
peut-être aux États-Unis avec pâte chino
et de Niro d'autres d'autres grands
acteurs qui à un moment donné domine la
scène
et surtout pour revenir sur ces deux
personnes ils avaient effectivement de
charme particulier
l'un plus mis angélique médiabolique
pour de long et l'autre goyailleurs
cette le président de la République a
assisté là-dessus il a dit
qu'effectivement c'était un titi
parisien qui d'origine italienne mais il
était il était il symbolisé Paris
saint-brisait il symbolisait la France
de Delon c'est une c'est c'est un
candidat c'est un personnage assez un
personnage à part de ce point de vue là
sur les images on voit maintenant
monsieur
du jardin non alors oui ça c'est du
jardin on a juste en aperçu le petit
garçon qui jouait dans l'as déjà
donc il est beaucoup plus âgé on l'a en
traversé juste avant
il avait rencontré
Charlotte je sais pas si vous souvenez
il y avait un petit serrure de
chaussures
brésilien dans l'homme de Rio et
évidemment c'était il a rencontré il y a
quelques années pour un documentaire ils
sont revus 60 ans après évidemment le
petit le petit serveur de chaussures qui
avait 10 ans en 1960 avait 60 65 ou 70
ans 60 ans après c'était drôle alors
qu'on le voit sur ces images la cour
d'honneur des Invalides qui s'est vidée
les invités Laurent Gerra et là
évidemment était très amie avec Lautner
parce qu'il y avait il y avait la bande
à Beyblade du Conservatoire mais quand
même il y avait la bande à l'autre mère
et l'autre mère jusqu'à sa mort en 2013
il est mort l'année du cinquantenaire
d'être conflingueurs rassemblait dans
son moulin à Grasse il avait une
propriété à Grasse et il rassemblait
Belmondo de tous les acteurs qui avaient
joué dans ses films c'était vraiment un
chef de bande et mon ami Venantino
Venantini a passé quelques été avec
Belmondo qui venait régulièrement
et donc la mort de Lautner a été aussi
le problème c'est tout à l'heure je
crois que c'est son c'est son fils ou le
président qui c'est qui a parlé de ça
c'est qu'évidemment il souffrait ces
dernières années et la mort de Charles
Gérard est symbolique de ça de la
disparition de tous ses amis quand on
regarde
bedo c'est mort il y a un an
Rochefort il y a deux ans Marielle etc
et donc c'est c'était terrible c'est
terrible je pense que c'est réellement
la mort de Charles Gérard a dû le adulte
peiner parce que c'était un peu le
dernier de ces grands copains alors s'il
reste Vernier mais c'est c'était à la
certainement pas tous les jours avec
vernis
si vous nous rejoignez en direct et bien
nous venons d'assister à une cérémonie
émouvante cet hommage national à
Jean-Paul Belmondo qui s'était éteint
lundi dernier à l'âge de 88 ans je vous
le disais 700 invités dont on voit le
départ maintenant des personnalités du
monde de du cinéma de la culture du
sport des politiques également qui sont
en train de s'étreindre encore sous le
coup de l'émotion de cette cérémonie
très forte avec l'éloge funèbre
prononcées par Emmanuel Macron chef de
l'État puis par juste avant Victor
Belmondo le petit fils l'un des
petits-fils de Jean-Paul Belmondo et
puis le départ du cercueil sur cette
musique d'Ennio Morricone du
professionnel qui nous a tous bouleversé
et je pense que le public qui était
présent l'été aussi je crois que
Thibault isaurait est en direct en ce
moment sur l'esplanade des Invalides
avec l'un de ces
fans de Jean-Paul Belmondo qui s'est
déplacée aujourd'hui spécialement pour
vivre cet événement depuis l'esplanade
des Invalides Thibault isaurès si vous
entendez c'est à vous dites nous tout de
l'émotion de de cette personne que vous
avez à vos côtés si vous m'entendez
on dirait que depuis la couronneur des
Invalides mille personnes qui n'avaient
pas besoin de s'inscrire mais personne
qui se sont présentées
les premières arrivées les premiers
rentrées on va dire seuls étaient
nécessaires un pass sanitaire et puis
pour permettre à ce public venu en
nombre aujourd'hui saluer
Jean-Paul Belmondo et ben des grands
écrans avaient été installés sur
l'esplanade des Invalides pour leur
permettre d'assister en direct à cette
cérémonie qui se voulait populaire un
hommage national certes solennel avec
les honneurs militaires avec l'éloge
funèbres du chef de l'État du chef des
armées mais malgré tout avec un discours
Bertrand Guillard si on peut revenir un
peu sur sur le discours de du chef de
l'État marqué par par des mots forts qui
reflétaient bien
Jean-Paul Belmondo qui a redit à quel
point il représentait cette France
heureuse ce côté solaire sa gouaille
solaire a-t-il dit et c'est c'est
cascades évidemment hors pair
qu'est-ce qu'on peut redire de nouveau
sur cette cérémonie qui nous a tous un
peu bouleversé
la musique de du professionnel moi m'a
fait monter les larmes aux yeux le
discours du président moi je l'ai trouvé
très bien fait mais au fond c'était
c'était très bien fait et puis on avait
nous on avait pensé qu'il allait être un
discours nostalgique il l'était il a
tout fait pour qu'il soit pas
complètement nostalgique il a évité le
passéisme mais il est quand même on
était quand même dans la nostalgie et je
moi je voulais avoir mon avis je vais
vous le dire c'était on avait quand même
l'impression qu'il entérait à travers
Belmondo une France qui n'est plus
tellement et qu'on va effectivement
qu'on va peut-être retrouver dans le
cinéma mais
voilà ce que je pense
une page est tournée c'est peut-être
aussi le sentiment de cette personne qui
est en ce moment sur l'esplanade des
Invalides aux côtés de notre envoyé
spécial Thibault Israël qui a assisté en
direct à cette cérémonie grâce aux
écrans géants installés sur place pour
le public Thibault ils auraient si vous
m'entendez ben c'est à vous
dites-nous un peu ce qu'on pensait c'est
français et français venus assister
spécialement aujourd'hui à cet hommage
national
merci beaucoup Charlotte en effet
beaucoup d'émotions d'ailleurs plusieurs
personnes qui refusent de parler car
elles sont un petit peu dans l'émotion
vous les voyez ces personnes qui bien ce
tendent le long de la rue pour voir les
véhicules passés et vivre encore un
petit peu les quelques instants qu'il
reste à vivre de cette journée
historique je vous propose toutefois de
partir à la rencontre de Rosine bonjour
Rosine merci d'accepter de de nous
parler beaucoup d'émotions on imagine
pour vous aujourd'hui notamment avec ce
dernier hommage musical qu'est-ce que
vous avez ça va vous a fait vivre
aujourd'hui pour moi personnellement
c'était un grand acteur comme il y en
aura jamais plus voilà tous les plus
grands partent hélas voilà maintenant ce
qui reste c'est 0
voilà pourquoi avoir choisi de venir ici
même sur cette pelouse aujourd'hui pour
vivre ce moment
pour lui rendre hommage
c'était quelqu'un qui était certainement
très gentil très très gentil plus que
gentil humain et voilà et ça vous fait
croire tant de personnes rassemblées ton
émotion aujourd'hui
c'est
une personne qui était aimée donc les
gens lui rendent comme ceci
et je crois que ça va voir que vous
souhaitez justement pouvoir accéder
ensuite pour des Invalides peut-être
pour rendre un dernier roman exactement
je se ferai donc assister pour lui avoir
une grosse pensée pour cet homme et là
ce qui est parti voilà merci beaucoup je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de journée
Thibault isaurait de nous avoir permis
d'entendre le témoignage d'une fan de
Jean-Paul Belmondo d'une française qui a
tant aimé ce comédien solaire et qui
nous a tous bouleversé à la danse de sa
mort merci encore de nous avoir suivis
en direct à vous qui nous suivez et sur
le Figaro.fr et sur Youtube merci pour
vos commentaires merci pour votre
émotion transmise par vos mots vous avez
été j'imagine bouleversé comme nous
l'avons été
je vous suggère et je vous recommande
très fortement de vous tourner vers le
hors-série le numéro spécial édité par
Le Figaro est consacré à au magnifique à
ce magnifique Jean-Paul Belmondo né en
1933 et donc décédé ce lundi à 88 ans un
numéro spécial que vous retrouvez
évidemment dans vos kiosques à journaux
et puis en précommande sur le Figaro
store.fr si la régie peut nous montrer
cette magnifique couverture de ce hors
série ce serait formidable Le Figaro
hommage le magnifique avec je vous la
montrer parce que je l'ai en papier elle
est comme ça cette couverture elle est
un peu petite puisque c'est une copie
mais voilà on l'a sur le merci beaucoup
Riyad
en régie de nous montrer
la couverture de ce hors-série consacrée
à Jean-Paul Belmondo merci beaucoup
Bertrand Guyard un journaliste
spécialiste de Jean-Paul Belmondo au
service culture du Figaro d'avoir été
avec nous d'avoir commenté ces images
émouvantes et nous avoir transmis
également votre émotion aujourd'hui
on vous retrouve demain Bertrand
Guillard on sera de nouveau avec vous
qui nous suivait pour cette fois-ci
couvrir et vous faire vivre et commenter
les obsèques de Jean-Paul Belmondo qui
auront lieu dans Paris en l'église
Saint-Germain-des-Prés à Paris à 11h
nous serons en direct sur Le Figaro.fr
Figaro live et sur Youtube également
10h30 demain matin
voilà c'est fini je vous propose qu'on
se quitte avec quelques-unes des plus
belles scènes tournées par Jean-Paul
Belmondo dans ses meilleurs films
prenez-y du plaisir
monsieur va peut-être nous offrir un
verre
alors qu'il est d'ailleurs vous devriez
déjà être chez vous je suis sûr que vous
avez un parent de la famille un fiancé
qui vous attend papa Langlois tombe de
sommeil quand un mémère elle tient plus
debout
[Musique]
le plus grand de tous
les
IEN
de la statue de mon père le professeur
catalan
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'aimez pas la mer
[Musique]
si vous n'aimez pas à la montagne
si vous n'aimez pas la ville
allez vous faire [ __ ]
[Musique]
bonjour dis-moi bonjour comme si j'étais
un malade
bonjour
mon père était grave timoré pénétré du
souci de respectabilité
je t'avais dit que je serai toujours
derrière toi
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as l'air triste
parce que tu me parles avec les mots que
moi je te regarde avec tes sentiments
et toi on peut pas avoir de conversation
c'est pas vrai il y a des idées dans les
sentiments
on va essayer d'avoir une conversation
sérieuse que désires-tu encore
rien du tout parce que je peux tout
donner je peux tout avoir c'est vrai
c'est même plus amusant
oh si Dominique
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la valeur
permettez-moi de vous dire que c'est le
Bill intégral
vous permettez mais je vous en prie
Julie tu peux venir coucher je
t'expliquerai je vais pas vous déranger
à cette heure du soir
bon bah d'accord d'accord continuez
[Musique]
comme votre peau va bien avec Bach